you know when i was a kid every time i
heard the word mistake i thought of the
word bacon
and i don't know why i don't know why
mistake makes me think of bacon but i
will say
that if i got a piece of bacon for every
time i made a mistake
like i'd make mistakes all the time
because it'd be a very rewarding
experience
for making a mistake getting a piece of
bacon god i love bacon
anyway enough rambling on about nonsense
so back with another video blog and um
you know just so you guys know when it
comes to the video making process when i
make my videos
it takes me about three days or so
sometimes three and a half days because
it's a pretty lengthy process you know i
put
um you know as much effort as i can into
making my videos so i wanted to be
quality videos and so in order for them
to be quality
it's going to take some time for me to
upload them but i was thinking
you know anything that a content
provider can do here on youtube
to make their subscribers feel more part
of the channel is always a good thing
and so i was kind of debating on the
idea uh how would you guys feel about
having like a day to yourselves you know
a day for you guys to
you know have a video that you want to
see i mean if you guys want to spend
like a week you know when you guys
give me your suggestions or send me your
suggestions and like a message or
something like that and i'll go through
all the all the suggestions you guys
send me
and the most popular one is the one that
i'll do a video on or if you guys want
to post up comments or something like
that or
we can do like a video i can do like an
upload you know a quick two minute
upload or
30 second upload saying you know it's
your time again to let me know what you
guys want to see and you guys can just
post like all your ideas in the comments
and then uh
and then i can do a video the next video
i'll do after that will be based on the
one that you guys want to see so
let me know if you guys are interested
in that kind of thing because you know
i think that you know i've been on
youtube for quite some time i've been on
youtube for about three or four years
not in the sense of actually like
producing videos i had an old youtube
channel that i use for call of duty but
i don't do that anymore
but you know i've been around youtube
long enough to see
all different kinds of content providers
come and go
and some have stayed longer than others
and some are still here and um
you know i've seen people who who get on
and they make videos but their
subscribers offer suggestions and they
offer requests and things like that and
those requests just never get fulfilled
and you know to me it really just kind
of seems like you're letting your
subscribers down i guess
or maybe kind of uh alienating them a
little bit because i think that when it
comes to youtube
you know as a person who's producing
videos and as a person who's been a
subscriber you know i know what it's
like on both ends and i kind of feel
like
you know when you make a submission for
a request and
that request doesn't get fulfilled
that's one thing but when you make a
submission for a request and that
request is entirely ignored that's
another
and it really is kind of a letdown so to
speak you know i think that
i wouldn't go as far as to say that i
think in my opinion should be heard
every single time i voice it somewhere
on youtube
but i will say that i think that that as
a person who has been a subscriber for
various channels
um it's kind of disappointing when you
make a request and and there's no
acknowledgement of that request
whatsoever so
um you know i really don't want to put
you all in that position i don't want to
make you guys feel like you know what
you
want to see on this channel isn't
relevant and all i'm uploading is what i
want to upload
you know i want to make sure you guys
know that you know that your opinions
matter here and your requests matter
and you know like i've said before time
and time again you know i'm here to
bring you guys stuff that you want to
see
and i'm doing the best i can to bring
you the best version of the content that
you guys are interested in seeing and so
you know if you guys have ideas on any
way that i can improve this channel you
know if you guys have
suggestions on videos that you want to
see then let me know and if you guys are
receptive to this idea of taking a day
and you guys just kind of voicing your
own thing and
and uh you know having a video to
yourselves basically where you can
it can be the one thing that you've
wanted to see the most then let me know
and uh and we'll go ahead and we'll try
to see if we can't get that iron down
and see if we can get that figured out
and and and go from there
so with that being said i'm gonna go
ahead and bring this video to an end
hope you guys enjoyed it if you did let
me know
and i will catch you guys later peace
so again i don't really know what
direction this channel is going to take
in terms of how big we're going to get
but i do think that we have amazing days
ahead of us and i really do think that
we are going to have some great
discussions and some great topics
and i really do think this channel is
going to grow to something absolutely
fantastic
in the realm of youtube